[Música]
las autoridades mexicanas trasladaron a
Ciudad de México a Ovidio Guzmán hijo
del narcotraficante Joaquín El Chapo
Guzmán tras su captura en Sinaloa El
operativo desató bloqueos de vías y
enfrentamientos en ese estado del
noroeste mexicano
Estados Unidos anunció una ampliación de
su programa de permisos humanitarios
para migrantes y recibirá 30.000
personas al mes provenientes de
Venezuela Cuba Nicaragua y Haití por vía
aérea eso al tiempo que la Casa Blanca
anunció que expulsará de inmediato a
México a los migrantes que intenten
entrar de forma irregular
la cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos continúa sin presidente tras 11
rondas fallidas de votación que se
retoma este viernes el boicot de los
ultraconservadores a Kevin mccarthy no
ha permitido que gane la elección
mientras aumenta la tensión porque el
órgano no puede legislar sin portavoz
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
México porque las autoridades capturaron
a Ovidio Guzmán hijo del narcotraficante
Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán en el Estado de
Sinaloa en un operativo que desató
violencia en las calles y dejó al menos
tres fallecidos el informe es de lluís
Muñoz el narco mexicano se volvió a
tomar las calles de Sinaloa 19 cortes de
vía
coches calcinados y disparos
contraviones de la fuerza aérea e
incluso contra uno de pasajeros de
Aeroméxico una ola de terror el jueves
después de la detención de uno de los
hijos del narcotraficante Joaquín El
Chapo Guzmán después de controlar la
agresión directa en contra de las
fuerzas de seguridad se identificó a
Ovidio n entre los integrantes de este
grupo delincuencial logrando su
aseguramiento en posesión de armamento
exclusivo del ejército y fuerza aérea
mexicanos por favor pase por favor
También conocido como El ratón Ovidio
junto con dos hermanos forma la sección
de los chapitos o los menores dentro del
Cartel De Sinaloa se hizo famoso en 2019
la guardia nacional le detuvo pero tras
la respuesta del narco en las calles de
Sinaloa El presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador ordenó liberarle
finalmente este jueves fue la vencida
siendo trasladado a Ciudad de México
para lograrlo se detuvo la vida en
Sinaloa sigue trabajando las autoridades
de gobierno para controlar la situación
se sigue invitando a la ciudadanía para
que no esté en la calle la detención se
produce días antes de la visita del
presidente Joe bydena México Estados
Unidos Busca su extradición por cargos
de narcotráfico lo que representa un
giro en la estrategia inicial de López
Obrador de abrazos no balazos
seguimos en Estados Unidos porque el
presidente Joe biden anunció un cambio
en la política migratoria del país para
hacer frente a la presión en su frontera
con México 30.000 personas provenientes
de Venezuela Cuba Nicaragua y Haití
serán aceptadas cada mes pero deberán
hacer su solicitud desde otro país y
llegar por vía aérea además habrá
sanciones para quien cruce la frontera y
legalmente Rodrigo cedano tiene los
detalles
no se presenten sin más en la frontera
quédense donde están y presenten su
solicitud legalmente Desde allí es la
petición que Joe biden hizo a quienes
quieren llegar a Estados Unidos al
tiempo que anunció cambios en la
política migratoria del país desde ahora
otorgará 30.000 permisos humanitarios
mensuales a migrantes de Venezuela
Nicaragua Cuba y Haití pero deben hacer
su solicitud desde otro país
pero esto es importante si las personas
de estos países intentan cruzar las
fronteras estadounidenses sin permiso o
la mexicana o la panameña desde hoy no
serán elegibles para esta vía legal el
mensaje es claro deben quedarse donde
están y aplicar Desde allí
para obtenerlo necesitarán un
patrocinador en territorio
estadounidense pero con el permiso
podrán vivir y trabajar durante dos años
en el país si los solicitantes intentan
cruzar ilegalmente la frontera serán
expulsados y vetados por cinco años para
este nuevo proceso el cambio afecta a
toda la región
los retos hemisféricos requieren
soluciones hemisféricas y estamos
trabajando estrechamente con los
gobiernos de toda la región para crear
vías legales
con este fin vaiden viajará el domingo
por primera vez hasta la ciudad del paso
fronteriza con México más tarde en la
semana se reunirá también con el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador cuyo país ya se comprometió a
[__] a 30.000 migrantes deportados al
mes
y durante tres jornadas y once
votaciones la cámara de representantes
de Estados Unidos aún no ha logrado
elegir presidente que debe ser
republicano por la mayoría en esta
legislatura Kevin mccarthy no ha podido
triunfar en la elección a causa del
boicot de los republicanos
ultraconservadores la votación se
reanudará a mediodía del viernes la
insólita situación de que se requieran
más de 10 rondas para elegir a un
portavoz no ocurría en ese órgano
legislativo desde
1859 se trata del Tercer cargo más
importante del país tras el presidente
Joe biden y la vicepresidenta kamala
Harris que preside el senado la elección
en la cámara baja requiere 218 votos una
cifra que no se ha alcanzado en ninguna
ronda Andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
de la trayectoria de Kevin mccarthy
Kevin mccarthy es un hombre de 57 años
que vive en un Distrito conservador en
el estado demócrata por excelencia
California desde que llegó a Washington
en 2007 quiere presidir la cámara de
representantes en 2015 casi gana la
Silla cuando el republicano johner
anunció su renuncia pero los choques con
los representantes del freedom Cocos el
ala más conservadora de los republicanos
se lo impidieron los mismos que ahora se
han opuesto a que sea elegido cuando la
entonces presidenta de la cámara Nancy
pelosi inició uno de los juicios
políticos contra Donald Trump mccarthy
fue uno de los que se opuso
la presidenta de esta cámara pero no
habla por Estados Unidos cuando se trata
de este tema no puede decidir
unilateralmente lo que sucede aquí han
estado investigando a este presidente
incluso antes de que fuera electo han
votado tres veces sobre juicio político
Aquí
también hizo eco de las acusaciones
infundadas de fraude de Trump al perder
la presidencia y a un recuento de los
votos
cada recuento debe terminarse tenemos
desafíos dentro de los tribunales cada
demanda debe ser escuchada
independientemente de a quien apoye en
esta elección al final del día queremos
que Estados Unidos esté Unido
Aunque republicano condenó el asalto al
Capitolio y denunció el comportamiento
de Donald Trump semanas después fue amar
al agua retractarse y a intentar
recuperar el aprecio del hombre que una
vez le llamó mi Kevin el portavoz de la
cámara de representantes es la tercera
persona con más poder en Estados Unidos
tras el presidente Joe biden y la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris
la asamblea nacional opositora de
Venezuela elegida en 2015 designó a
Dinora figuera como cabeza de la nueva
junta directiva de ese parlamento
paralelo al que controla el oficialismo
en esa nación figuera sustituye en el
cargo a Juan guaidó que hasta el pasado
30 de diciembre También lideró el
parlamento opositorio el gobierno
interino de ese país que fue eliminado
por los mismos legisladores la figura de
figuera es clave para conformar una
comisión delegada que se encargará de
determinar cómo se manejan los activos
del país que están congelados en el
exterior durante la misma jornada el
parlamento oficialista eligió por
tercera vez a Jorge Rodríguez como
presidente
[Aplausos]
este 5 de enero continuaron las
protestas en Perú con numerosos bloqueos
en vías principales entre ellas la
Panamericana Sur la más importante del
país lo que está dificultando el
transporte de alimentos y materias
primas los manifestantes siguieron
pidiendo la renuncia de la presidenta
Dina boluarte y condenaron el proceso
contra el destituido presidente Pedro
Castillo Al igual que la represión en
las manifestaciones de diciembre en las
que alrededor de 30 personas perdieron
la vida las protestas ya han generado la
cancelación de un 60% de las reservas de
turismo durante la primera mitad de 2023
quiero reconocer seguramente
a los hermanos y hermanas que aún salen
en las manifestaciones justas a ellos y
a ellas
lestiendo nuevamente mi mano y mi
corazón abierto para ponernos a sentar
sobre una mesa Y conversar sobre las
necesidades que están planteando inició
en la ciudad estadounidense de Las Vegas
el electronic show la feria tecnológica
que anualmente atrae a miles de
entusiastas para ver de primera mano las
más recientes innovaciones la versión de
este año tiene un especial sentido
porque en 2022 el evento fue
notoriamente reducido por la variante
omicron del covid 19 el llamado es la
muestra tecnológica más grande a nivel
mundial y se extenderá hasta el domingo
ocho de enero
finalizamos en Chile donde integrantes
de la armada lograron rescatar a un
perrito que quedó Atrapado en una roca
gigante en la desembocadura del río bío
bío en la comuna de hualpén los
responsables informaron que el rescate
fue particularmente difícil debido a la
inclinación de las rocas sin embargo era
urgente recuperar al animal que llevaba
cuatro días sin comida ni agua el can
recibió atención veterinaria su llegada
a Tierra Firme y según medio será dado
en adopción
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]